I'm really excited as you can tell
because we're starting a topic today now
some of you have encountered this topic
before it's very very it's very
different to all the other topics that
we've been doing but it connected
beautiful ways to so many other parts
over the course that you very much so
to set the table to set the table I want
to explain to you the two different
kinds of logic that basically are
functioning together here and make up
mathematical induction
so first started deduction because
deduction is actually what we've been
doing in mathematics well since ever
since you've been doing mathematics
you've been deducing ok
what does deduction new order that is to
balance if you take things you know
right
so think about deductive geometry ok I
know these sides are equal I know these
angle 1 angle is double the size of that
angle is supplementary whatever you take
things that you know should be true do
you apply some logic right and that
logic often takes the form of results
that you've proven before such as all
angles in a triangle add up to 180
degrees
that's a piece of logic which you can
apply to it train that you have to know
some angles you take the known facts you
apply logic and then you draw
conclusions
this link is going to be whatever right
this angle is going to be whatever and
then this straight line from stuff you
know to stuff you didn't know before but
I basically this logic it's water time
we can do an absolute 70 industry now
the induction is totally different
inductive logic
has a similar kind of structure but the
pieces are very very different inductive
logic is to say take rather than fact
it's to take a small number of pieces
take a small number of cases I'm gonna
illustrate is to your non mathematical
terms in a second if you have a small
number of cases where you observe
something happening again it starts to
make you substance suspicious so instead
of applying logic because I don't have
like facts here I've just seen something
happen a few times I'm going to apply a
generalization right I think there's a
patent you a patent I can take advantage
of and even if I don't have all of the
cases in front of me I can still draw
some conclusions on the basis of the
generalization that I think is in
operation
okay so deduction which is what we used
to and induction now just think about
this for a second
in most cases we actually say induction
is a bad thing to have in mathematics
right it's just because something is
true a few times that's no guarantee at
all that is always true so this when you
see it applied like this is kind of
flimsy right it's like well what if
that's all number of cases you got was
just oh but we in case it's right now
there's just a bit of so the induction
in its normal form is kind of
probabilistic is the way that they would
say it's probably true so let me give
you an example let's talk about Berger
induction if I go to a like you know a
restaurant that sells burgers okay
they'll never be to before they might
have saved 50 different kinds of burgers
there to three different kinds of now
I'm not trying the first burger all
right go to the menu here oh that's all
right
you tried begging one and it turns out
to be like something that gives you
suggestions it's like okay would you
like some burger with that oil in her
it's just
easy like okay this is disappointing but
you say that's okay the 49 other purpose
obviously so just try the other one
right
you like fingers crossed behavior is
just bad luck and then it's like yeah
you know what
this one also disappointing also felt
like I've you know I lost three years of
my life after finishing this simple
negative same kind of pattern and then
because you're a subject replacement
you're like no 48 other options and what
have I got here
I have established a smiley of cases a
smaller number of cases with three out
of 50 but I think we all agree it is
reasonable at this point even if it's
not a hundred percent guaranteed it is
reasonable to apply generalization and
say you know what
I've been sick enough times at this
place I'm going to say what conclusion
could I draw for generalizing for this
yeah all beggars are crazy
yeah all voters at this place I'm gonna
say according to my generalization
that's my pants now like I said we could
be wrong they could be like one magical
burger but it takes us 49 to get through
it's like finally a good one okay so
this is not rock-solid logic okay but
it's pretty good we do this logic all
the time do we not like I think most
people would actually don't get to the
third burger before this like some
people would say just stop them let's
pick up that's enough that's enough
evidence to me so deductions induction
what does mathematical induction have to
do
mathematical induction says okay you
know what I'm not gonna take a small
number of cases your if I said to me I
kind of joked you know just one bad guy
some people say that's enough
mathematical induction takes not just a
small number of places it takes a super
mess right it chooses it very very
carefully and then instead of just
applying a generalization like I think
they're all gonna be like this what it
does this is what's clever about it is
it bakes
deductive logic even through the
generalization right so it's not just
like yeah I think this should always be
should always happen cuz it's happened
to one there's actually a lot of logic
that goes into produce you the
generalization so what you get out of
this this mathematical induction the
guts of it are actually still deductive
logic okay but the whole principle of
taking just one little thing and then
improving it as the case generally is
for an infinite number of cases I think
it's going to be true that's the way
mathematical induction works okay